- Do you have any?
- [Host] Prince Harry's Memoir
"Spare" is the latest release
from the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex's vast portfolio
of shows, podcasts and books.
After stepping down as working members
of the British Royal family in 2020,
no longer paid to represent the Crown,
the couple have explored
new income streams
as the next chapter of
their lives unfolds.
Here's what we do and don't know
about how Harry and
Meghan make their money.
- [Reporter] Harry, are you
pressing money before family?
Are you pressing money before family?
(group chattering)
- [Host] In "Spare", the
title and nod to having heir
and a spare to the throne.
Prince Harry speaks about topics ranging
from physical altercations
with his brother William
to losing his virginity to
an older woman behind a pub.
The couple signed a book deal
with Penguin Random House widely reported
to be worth $20 million
which includes the
headline grabbing Memoir.
- I called my publishers
rep right away and said,
put me on the list.
- The story is interesting
because it keeps evolving.
- I'm sure it's partially
due to a lifestyle
that they want and what can they sell?
- [Host] On the day of its
release, "Spare" was at the top
of Amazon's best sellers
list alongside the book deal,
there are multi-year agreements
with Netflix and Spotify
reported to be worth roughly $120 million.
Harry and Meghan will make
content for the two platforms
through divisions of their
Art Trail organization.
Their first offering for Netflix,
a six-part documentary series
had the streaming services
biggest debut for a documentary
titled by hours viewed
the company said.
- [Harry] We all have greatness within us.
- [Host] Harry also has a
job at the Silicon Valley
startup Better Up as Chief Impact Officer.
His compensation package was not disclosed
but jobs with that title
boast an average salary
of $140,000 according to talent.com.
The due conductors also
received an unknown
but substantial sum from Harry's father,
according to a spokesperson,
all together that would
total a lot more than the sum
they received from then
Prince Charles in 2020.
Financial releases from his estate reveal
the Sussex's, along with William and Kate
shared around $5.4 million
to fund their activities.
Now, Harry and Meghan have security costs
and living expenses to worry about.
They live in Montecito, California
where they bought a home
for over $14 million
and there was the small task
of paying the Crown back
the estimated 3 million it cost
to renovate Frogmore Cottage
in Windsor, Harry and Meghan lived there
after they were married,
until they moved to the US.
Leaving the family business, so to speak,
has opened up a world of new
opportunities for the couple
but their sources of
revenue are less secure.
At least King Charles III
has a guaranteed income
from his property estates
and public funding.
Representatives of the Duke Duchess
didn't immediately respond
to a request for comment.
It is possible Harry and
Meghan will need to continue
making commercial deals to
sustain their lifestyle.
(upbeat music)